hi yvonne how are you i'm good how are
you doing
so nice meeting you uh so this movie was
so
entertaining i mean there's heart in it
but there's just so much kick-ass-ness
which i love especially from your
character
um when you consider the whole cast if
there was really an alien invasion who
do you think would be the first to
volunteer to save the world
oh uh i mean i think edwin
yeah character yeah i mean he's such a
badass in the film i mean he's he's
he's all there and he knows exactly how
to handle himself and
yeah so you don't think chris pratt even
though he plays all these heroes in
these films you don't think chris pratt
would be the first volunteer
i mean you know i think i'm still gonna
go with edwin on this one
i really sorry chris if if you're
listening
i love that so much well speaking of
chris obviously
you had such fantastic emotional scenes
with him uh you know you're starring
opposite him in this film it's the first
film he's executive produced
what was it like working with him kind
of with him at the helm of this film
it was wonderful i mean he's a lovely
guy we had
a great rapport on set i mean we was
really collaborative which was so
important
for this uh for the role and
for the kind of relationship that we
have in the film
um yeah i mean everyone was so lovely to
work with
our director who who uh
it was just so surprising to have you
know someone like chris come from the
strong animation world come in and
and really create the space for for
chris pratt and i to be able to
to really go to the depths that we
needed to to to create sort of the
grounding emotional force
that that bubbles underneath this like
action-packed
movie and what was the in terms of i
mean there's just so much action going
on here with the training or just kind
of like getting in the headspace is that
fun
it was so fun i i it was definitely
challenging just um going through
weapons training um and and feeling like
my arms were gonna drop off after the
first two hours
but uh but you know and just wondering
my god i really should have lifted more
weights or just a weight
just one weight um before i started the
film
so so yeah it was really fun getting
back into the action world
that's cool uh well i do have to ask
about the handmaid's tale season four
finale's coming up
how satisfied are you with this episode
oh i i mean that's the word i keep using
when people ask me about the finale the
the the season finale i
personally think it's the most
satisfying
end to a season that we've had i i
certainly when i read it i was like
oh you know it's it's just yeah
i think i think everyone's jaws are
gonna be on the floor it's it's really
exciting
and it and unnecessary and fun
ish with a little devilish grin there i
like
that do you ever uh read the scripts and
you kind of hold your breath a little
bit just to make sure your character
does survive and and
everything's okay um
yeah i guess i sometimes i've thought if
uh you know
i wondered about whether i'm sticking
around or not
um uh but no i mean
it's always exciting to read the scripts
i mean they're so
they're so well written crafted
um that you really you can't put them
down so
it it's such a joy to a joy uh pun
not intended um to be part of of the
show
well i can't wait to watch the finale
you're so good in this movie congrats i
can't wait for everyone to see it's
going to be awesome
thank you thanks very much
you